[Music]
revolutionary songs play out as
activists board buses taking them to
Tripoli it's the first time they've come
together from different parts of the
country to meet in the poorest city in
Lebanon we came from Beirut to thank
Tripoli for all the support everything
she did for Beirut and all every single
region came here also to the theme of
today is hand in hand so we're putting
our hand together the powder hands the
one heart one blood and one heartbeat
just weeks ago protestors nationwide
celebrated forcing former Prime Minister
side of Heloise government to resign but
they're still unhappy they're concerned
the new government is cut out of the
same cloth a political elite that won't
meet their demands anytime soon the new
cabinet is due to receive a vote of
confidence in Parliament next week but
protesters don't trust those at the helm
and are worried about the future they've
suffered for years from deep rooted
corruption power cuts and a lack of
basic public services they say their
revolution is not dead yet despite
dwindling numbers there are two issues -
really really urgent issues one is like
another crisis - is the dependency of
the court system
first it's not acceptable anymore that
the ship is sinking there's a real sense
of community at this demonstration from
free soup kitchens to a discussion forum
bringing together different movements
and civil societies they talk about
wanting a government that will be held
accountable and despite the diversity
here they all agree on one thing the
need to work hand in hand in challenging
the government and making sure their
demands are met
hire at al jazeera Tripoli